let's start with the algebra section
first topic okay
simplifying it started off nice and easy
so all you have to do is collect
like terms here you've got your 2x and
your x
some of you would have helpfully
actually written on there you know put
some marks underneath
the like terms and then you can see 2x
minus x just gives you 1.
then 5y 3y 5 plus 3 gives you 8 so
that's what gives you the answer there
so yeah i had d but
it's crossed out okay i'll have a look
at it
again if you've got any queries like
maybe something's been marked wrong or
maybe you don't understand
the explanation i give let me just hold
off on to the end so i can just jet
through the answers as quickly as
possible
okay um make a note separately rather
than make notes on your
paper because otherwise it's kind of
like they'll say oh well you might have
changed it afterwards or something like
that
okay so that's why another reason why
you sort of have your own book
okay the perimeter of this triangle
let's have a look now you've got to do
these um these three sides here
perimeter means you've got to add up all
of the lengths so that's why you can see
this working
over here so again it ends up being
collection of like terms you've got two
x's here
that gives you 2x when you do 2 minus 4
that's minus 2 plus 6 gives you the plus
4
okay so when you collect those like
terms
that part's probably the trickiest that
ends up with the 4 there so 2x
4 is your perimeter okay moving
further if x equals seven and y equals
four find the value of this so you had
to substitute them in
so instead of x you had to do two times
seven
right so that's what you can see here
instead of y you had to do y equals four
so there's that minus four there
two times seven is fourteen and that's
what gives you ten
okay further down okay maybe i'll try
and zoom in a little bit
make that a bit easier is that better
yeah okay good
so here you had to do two things you had
to expand this
and then you had to again collect
collect like terms so when you expand
two times x five you can think of
remember it's kind of like the two
has to shake hands with the x and with
the five just you know being polite
so that's why you get 2x plus 10 the
minus 4 is just kind of hanging out on
the side
it's not inside the bracket so that's
why it doesn't get doubled okay
the 2x there are no other like terms 10
minus 4 is 6.
that's where that answer comes from
all right moving down simplify now oh
sorry with your index notation
if you remember what n to the power of
five what it stands for
it's it's n times n times end
five times so if i wrote that out n
times m times m
times n there you go there's five of
them that's n to the five
okay if i want to do n to the four same
idea except
there's four of them so there's n to the
five and there's
n to the four so i've just written it
out in log hand
now how many ends are there being
multiplied in total and it's nine
it's five plus four so that's where your
end of the nine comes from
okay so that's about recognizing your
index laws
here they step it up a little bit you
can see you've got
three things you've got to treat
separately you've got the fives and the
seven the numbers
so you do them that's what you get 35
from you've got the
letter p so you've got a p cubed and a p
to the that's
that's actually a one there right so
three plus one
gives you the four and then you've got a
q that's also
one to the power of one q to the eight
one plus eight gives you known so you've
got the three things you've got to do
all separately in order to get the one
it's very easy
to muddle them up okay so if you got
that one wrong that might have been why
now when you go to this one simplify
this because division
just to write it out again i'll just
skip writing the times
signs if i do 9 of them that's that's 7
8 9 and i'm dividing by 6 of them
so just like you normally would with a
fraction you can cancel things out you
can cancel that one
that one that one you can cancel six
from the top and
six from the bottom which well i've
cancelled one too many sorry
so you're left with three because nine
minus six is three
so your index laws here and here is what
was being tested
for all of these really um here
m to the it's a bit hard to read 5 all
squared
right so again that's 5 m's
times 5 m's
because that's what squared means right
you multiply something by itself so how
many m's are there in total
there are 10. simplify this works the
same way but the trick was
that you've got to square the 3 and
square the m
because this is 3m times 3m
again that's what squared means right so
you've got the threes which become your
nine
and you've got your m's which become
your m squared
uh lastly here bit of a sneaky thing
here four
times m to the power of
zero now you might remember when we were
trying to work out the power of zero
um when you thought about you know m
one m two m three what they're short for
and if we went backwards and tried to to
look
you go here you divide by m you go here
you divide by m if you went one more
time
m to the power of zero that's just one
okay
so that's why four times one just gives
you four okay
so m over the page
factorizing so we did expanding in the
previous question so this is just in
reverse
you look at these two terms and you're
thinking about what's the common factor
okay so you can see you can take out the
3 that's good
but you can also take out the x so once
you've taken the 3x out the front
you think well what's left after i
divide this by 3x what's left is just
the y
what's left in this after you divide by
3x and it's just the two
so there's where your y and your plus
two come from
okay now then you start getting into the
fractions right
now here they start off with a simple
one where the denominators are the same
so since the denominators are the same
you just add the numerators together
and that's where you get 4 from the 11
stays put
okay just to give you a simpler example
without algebra right if i gave you a
half
plus a half everyone knows when you have
two halves you get one
right so numerically what are we talking
about here
that denominator stays the same and it's
the numerators that add together and two
over two of course is
one so we're applying the same principle
here it's just that there are letters
not
i'm sure there's some context that makes
sense of that okay now
13 you've got to change the denominator
don't you okay you've got 7 and 14 here
so to get a common denominator
uh you could multiply this one by 7 this
by 14. but it's much simpler
to just make this one over 14. then
they've got the common denominator
right so some of you would have when i
had to look through you you struggled to
work out what was the best common
denominator to get there's lots of
different ones
but the simplest one is 14. so what
you'd have to do is
if you're doubling the bottom to get 14
you've got to double the top to
to stay the same fraction okay so that's
why 3x becomes 6x
and the 7 becomes 14. once they're on
the same denominator you've got the same
scenario as you had here
and so you've got 6x minus 2x which is
go which gives you 4x
now that's that's good that's correct
but they did say
simplify right so therefore we should
really go from here
to here the difference you can see is
they've cancelled the factor of two okay
so that's the difference between this
and this you did have to go all the way
to here
when you're multiplying multiplying is
actually really easy isn't it you just
multiply the numerator and multiply the
denominator that's what gives you xy and
15.
when you do division all you have to do
is
dividing by for example if you divide by
2 that's the same as
multiplying by a half so division of
multiplication is same idea
if you take the reciprocal you turn the
number upside down
so that's why this 4 over b it turns
into
a b over four flips upside down becomes
multiplication
and then it's just like the previous
question okay
all right before we get to probability
i'll pause does anyone want me to
clarify any of the questions i went
through yeah
this one here yeah okay uh let me try
and give you a simple example
if i said okay 10
divided by 2. now you guys can all tell
me that that's
5 because we know how to do it with
numbers right but with fractions it's a
bit trickier
so the way we remember is 10 divided by
2 just following on this principle
is the same as 10 multiplied by a half
so you can see i've changed the division
it's multiplication
and i've changed this 2 into its
reciprocal
okay i've reversed it so that's 10 over
2 which as you were telling me before
is 5. okay so the point is that when you
divide by a fraction
you turn that fraction upside down this
was 2 over 1.
okay in the same way if i were to do it
this way
10 divided by half what would that be
equal to that's how many halves are
there in 10
the answer is there are 20 halves in 10
right but the way that i would write
that is
turn that division into multiplication
and i would flip this fraction upside
down it becomes 2.
that gives me the 20. there are 20
halves in 10. if i had 10 things and i
chopped them all in half i'd have 20 of
them
okay so that's why the way i try to
remember it that
the division turns into multiplication
you you get the reciprocal you flip the
fraction upside down
good question